one thing i campaigned on was that
it's unconscionable that higher
education has gotten two and a half
times more expensive over the last
number of years
and one of the jokes i used to pose was
like has it gotten two and a half times
better and that always got a laugh
because people were like it has not
really gotten two and a half times
better
no and then i posed the question to the
folks in the audience and was like hey
why has it gotten so expensive and then
they think about it for a minute
and then i say did we hire lots of
professors and they're like no
you know did we build lots of new
buildings and they were like maybe
and then i say that the real driver is
the fact that uh we've hired
150 percent more non-faculty
administrators uh at these universities
they've become these like overgrown
uh bureaucracies themselves and it's
become this hidden tax
on people on the middle class on folks
who are trying to
to uh give their kids a better life
and that's been building up for decades
in part because
any any college every year just looks
around and says okay how much are we
going to increase our prices by this
year
and so you have this this inflationary
effect that's unique to
health care and education and then
families felt like they had no choice
but to pay
so then the government said don't worry
about it we've got you
here are some loans so we're now up to
1.6 trillion
in student loan debt and i love the fact
that you work for nyu but you're honest
about the fact that look
these university administrators have
very clear financial incentives
like for going 400 million dollars in
tuition
is like uh you know like it it would
wreck
many of these institutions and so you
have many
schools that are bravely putting up uh
signals saying well hey we're going to
reconvene in the fall
and then you look at it and say like is
this what you would do if
this wasn't like an existential problem
for your school to forego
uh tuition revenue for a semester and
i would love to hear your ideas on how
we can somehow
help the university system
become more cost conscious and invest in
things that will actually improve kids
educational outcomes
as opposed to their us news and world
report rankings
yeah we are definitely brothers from
another mother i mean we your summary
it took me two years to get to the to
the
summary you just articulated in about
three minutes but
look we live in a capitalist society and
having more money means more opportunity
for your kids
access to better health care access to a
broader selection of mates it's just a
wonderful thing to have
more versus less money in a capitalist
society and all of us fall victim to
that in the sense that
when it's you're first and foremost
going to fix your own
oxygen mass and there's a belief that
universities are these very noble
institutions where we wear cardigans
watch pbs and pet our labrador and don't
think about money
and professors and administrators want
the same economic security as everyone
else
so by a combination of this dictum or
this gestalt where everybody has to get
a college education
where we constrain supply and become
luxury brands as opposed to public
servants
we consistently have been able to raise
prices through this kind of cartel
as you mentioned twice as fast as
inflation and we justify that we're
doing it for the right reasons but the
reality is
many universities especially elite and
universities have become hedge funds
that
provide classes to the children of their
investors and then we
wipe vaseline over the lens of the cast
structure that has been
that higher education has become by
letting in some freakishly remarkable
middle class and lower income kids
and to try and make ourselves kind of
the neosporin of our guilt
this is it's it's it's morally corrupt
and it is it is the spring used to be a
time
of nervousness but excitement about
where your kid was going to college
now it's become despair and anxiety
around how do i tell my little girl
that on a fireman's salary and maybe my
wife is
my wife is a doctor a nurse that we
can't afford to send her
to tulane how do you have that
conversation how do you
how do you feel like you're failing the
american dream
because you can't afford to after
working your ass off two income
you can't afford to send or you make a
worse decision and that is your kid
doesn't get into the top school because
they take pride in rejecting nine out of
ten applicants
and worse yet they go to a second tier
school where they don't get nearly the
upside because
corporations still look at those
universities in terms of evaluating your
currency in the marketplace and how much
they're going to pay you
but you incur elite university level
debt it's just this is one of the most
in my opinion
ugly parts of our society right now and
it's happened incrementally because like
anyone else
university administrators and professors
want to live the same great life
as anyone else what do we do about it
i've been spending a lot of time with
chancellor block who is the chancellor
of the
of my alma mater that receives more
applications than any university in the
world and that's the university of
california los angeles
and i've come to the conclusion that
these institutions are almost
constitutionally incapable of cutting
costs
between tenure between the
rolexification of their facilities
it is very hard for them and they
haven't had to cut costs for 40 years
it's almost impossible what we could do
is through a mix of small and big tech
potentially potentially
dramatically expand capacity if you were
to take 50
of your courses online and there are a
lot of courses that would be fine online
or a lot of sessions
where there isn't a lot of interaction
that you could facilitate online if you
take half your classes online
you effectively andrew double the size
of the campus
so what i would like to see and what i
would hope individuals like you that
might serve in a cabinet
or be in a position of of authority and
power someday is could we have some sort
of grand bargain where we go to
governors let's go to governor newsom
and say
increase the university of california
budget by 20 and we're going to
dramatically decrease the cost per
student educated through the use of
small and big tech by expanding our
capacity
and we're going to take ucla back from a
13 admit rate to where it was in the 90s
20 or 25. we have to dramatically expand
our land grant public universities
capacity such that
we can take good maybe not remarkable i
mean i don't know where you went to
school i was a remarkably
unremarkable kid and the reason i'm here
speaking to you today
is because ucla let in a third of its
applicants
and they could say to the son of a
single immigrant mother who lived and
died as secretary
let's be honest you're not great but we
like your profile you're a son of amer
of california we're going to let you in
they don't have the luxury of doing that
now
they don't have the luxury of letting in
kids with remarkable futures they have
to only let in the remarkable so i think
it's about
dramatically expanding through the use
of technology
freshman seats and also breaking this
wheel
where academics and administrators have
become drunk on exclusivity andrew every
year
the deans of the top schools including
mine get up and boast that we rejected
88
of our applicants that's tantamount to
the head of a housing shelter
bragging that he or she turned away nine
in 10 people who showed up last night we
have lost the script we need to move
back to being public servants as opposed
to luxury brands
we need to embrace technology and have
almost like a martial
martial act-like feel such that we take
capacity for our great public systems
university of texas
michigan university of california cal
state
cuny florida state systems and drama
and expand their seats by 30 or 50
percent i think a crisis is a terrible
thing to waste i think there's an
opportunity here
to move back to where we were where kids
who are unremarkable have remarkable
opportunities through the upward
lubricant that is
higher ed like we we need to examine
this from
soup to nuts like you look at and say
okay why is it four years why does it
cost this much
and to your point like why are you
getting rewarded for turning people down
like aren't you supposed to be a public
good
i love the fact that you've identified
public universities as the place to
launch this from because it makes the
most sense and and they should be
growing their seats like instead of a
proportion
of people you reject it should be
looking up society-wide and saying okay
how many 18-year-olds do we think are
like approximately
uh the right fit for what we're going
for
in terms of a public education and then
you should be rewarded for educating a
higher proportion of those people
which is like the reverse of the way
they get rewarded now yeah
if i'm in position to do this man i'm
100 gonna do it you're in you're in
because yeah like it comes down to a a
basic theme and
a shift in mindset and that is the
the worth of a society isn't the
opportunities it offers it's remarkable
it feels to me like the united states
and i'm curious to get your has moved
from
how do we give our truly remarkable
remarkable being people who are born
with
tremendous opportunities and also are
tremendously skilled
you know everyone says nyu is a place
for rich kids yeah but it's also rich
kids who are super impressive
they're remarkable do we just continue
to funnel more and more
of the spoils to that small segment who
are both blessed because they're born
into wealth and be very good remarkable
or isn't the judge of a society or the
worth of a society
what kind of opportunities it gives to
it's unremarkable what kind of
opportunities it gives to the kid
who maybe doesn't have access to the
test prep that you were offering who
maybe
has had challenges at home who maybe
doesn't at the age of 15
doesn't have a patent and isn't building
wells in africa and isn't captain of the
lacrosse team
i mean the kids that now get into these
schools we're
basically saying that the two the two
cohorts that are going to divide the
spoils of
of american productivity wages have not
gone up productivity skyrocketed that's
trillions of dollars in surplus
wealth that all goes to two cohorts
that's the children of rich kids or
people who are freakishly remarkable
between the ages of 15 and 17 who get
into harvard
we talk about these elite schools the
reason we talk i talk about the state
schools is
the ivs are more spectacle than historic
they educate they have 64 thousand total
students ohio state has fifty five
thousand florida state has seventy five
thousand berkeley will
graduate more kids from low income
household this year than the entire ivy
league combined so the ivy league
look fine your great leaders produced
leaders
childrens of rich kids remarkable kids
from middle and lower income households
but where america changes where america
fundamentally changes
is these land grant public schools that
educate two-thirds
two-thirds of our students and we're
going to need some sort of real dramatic
rethinking i think this is your platform
i think ubi
and education i think these are the two
legs of the stool i don't know what the
third one is andrew
for your next run you you'd have to say
healthcare everyone you have to say hell
because healthcare has some of the
similar problems
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]